on n'a pas le temps cela si on n'a pas
le temps se casser
vendredi 12 juin sur tf1 les artistes se
succèdent pour être la chanson de
l'année avec des danseurs l'un d'entre
eux est vie si noah christophe ouest
formée à hélices hit dance a vécu cette
émission comme une bouffée d'air frais
c'était une vraie chance de pouvoir
travailler même si ce n'est qu'une
semaine ça prend c'est toujours mieux
que rien pendant cette période là
d'ailleurs ils nous l'ont dit qu'on
était assez chanceux parce que pour les
artistes intermittents du spectacle
voilà il n'ya pas grand chose en ce
moment quoi on a fait tous les gestes
barrières qu'on pouvait pas de porte et
pas de contact physique dans les corps
et donc on danse tous à chaque fois un
mètre de distance entre nous du coup ça
joue sur un peu la création sur la
chorégraphie
eux aussi vont reprendre le chemin des
planches la troupe du crâne compagnie
semi-professionnels saint-quentinoise
répétera nouveau ce vendredi la
compagnie est très souvent sollicités
dans les châteaux franciliens on a des
consignes de sécurité c'est à dire qu'on
boit après des au cap avec des marques
mais dans la salle de répétition ça
c'est pas voir notre responsabilité
donc si nous ne souhaitons pas apporté
de martha komu car ses amis veulent et
il est maintenant dans notre troupe
on va d'abord essayer de nous et on va
péter la ville hier on va voir ce que ça
donne quand même une sorte de barrière
mais le son ne l'utilisera pas la
manière
christophe ouest continue la création
débuté juste avant le confinement avec
son trio la troupe du crâne et dans la
tente des nouvelles consignes
gouvernementales
les premiers projets pourraient se tenir
en septembre à l'occasion des journées
du patrimoine